normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government Alex
Jones's X account was reinstated by Elon
Musk the founder of conspiracy theory
website Infowars was banned from Twitter
currently known as X in 2018 and
reinstated in 2023 now I I do want to
just point out if you're going to call
Infowars a conspiracy theory website I
can call Snopes CNN The Washington Post
the New York Times The Wall Street
Journal the list goes on we can call
them all conspiracy theor uh conspiracy
theory websites because they all run
stories and have historically done so
like the idea that the government was
spying on us conspiracy theory oh was
that true how about Russia gate that was
one that wasn't true they all run lies
and conspiracies but they do use this
photo of a very angryl looking Alex
Jones claim in December 2023 conspiracy
theorist Alex Jones's Twitter account
real Alex Jones was reinstated by Elon
Musk after having been banned for
abusive Behavior since 2018 true I love
this one and then on a they show a
Reddit post Alex Jones and his
conspiracy theories are allowed back on
X here's the actual poll in question
with
1,966 1225 votes reinstate Alex Jones on
the platform vox populi Vox day and uh
70.1% said yes well there you have it of
course the media is absolutely losing
their mind over the return of Alex Jones
they're saying a whole bunch of really
dumb things and they're insulting Elon
Musk over the whole thing but uh let's
just call this a a major victory well
conspiracy theories are really just
spoiler alerts uh they're just news
headlines 6 months ahead of the time and
I am pissed off at the cultural
appropriation of something that I've
been labeled for over 20 years
conspiracy theories have of course a new
day and age on this internet as of
course no one takes the term seriously
anymore as a lot of the people who are
accused of it have usually been right
and it's beautiful it's amazing to see
this kind kind of emotional hyperbolic
freakout from CNN from the Rolling
Stones from all these other
establishment type Rags that are losing
their minds at people just being able to
speak for themselves and having
discernment and having conversations
that they can't control Al Gore recently
came out and said the dangers to
democracy are specifically because
people are able to get news outside of
the corporate media control we are
winning it's amazing it's beautiful and
them losing their mind is a testament to
just how far we have come yeah and I
think that that's exactly what they
sought to do they really thought that
they could get rid of Alex Jones and I
think that's been really interesting to
watch because if there's one thing that
I've noticed in the past couple of years
it's that they can cancel you from
certain platforms they can cancel you
from certain corporate corporations but
at the end of the day if you have a
certain following and you've been proven
right time and time again and that's
certainly the case with Alex Jones
you're still there's still going to be a
population of people that want to hear
from you they're going to seek you out
and as far as a business owner somebody
like Elon Musk if he's you know if he
owns X then it's going to be the smart
thing to do to allow him to be sought
out on his platform so I I think what
you see a lot with figures like Alex is
they just they try to they think that if
they remove the platform that they can
remove him but he already has his
following and that wasn't going anywhere
people were going to seek him out
regardless
Andre oh on the show on The X episode if
you haven't watched it after this show
you got to watch The X show where with
all these guys and Andrew Tate came in
he said everything people think they own
things you think you own your house you
have paperwork that says that if a
government comes in and says now they
sign some new paperwork you don't have
anything all you have is your integrity
and that's something that Alex has stuck
with for his entire career which I
appreciate and I think that's why he's
still popular I think Elon Musk is doing
the the obvious thing in terms of free
speech I don't believe that Elon Musk
ever really bought the reason for Alex
Jones's ban so uh when Elon buys Twitter
he says well you know Alex Jones raged
on you know Sandy Hook families and said
horrible things about him so I'm not
bringing him back I don't think Elon
actually believed it I think what Elon
was actually saying and again my my
opinion I could be totally wrong about
this because I can't read elon's mind he
was probably saying guys there's only so
much I can do like give give me time I
think Elon was like yeah he didn't break
the rules he's just says crazy things
but but elon's like yo we're trying to
maintain control here and gradually move
the line if we just go nuts and just
unleash the damn right now we can get
shut down like they did to parlor but I
think there's actually something really
simple and all this too we can sit here
and say Elon Musk is ideologically
motivated and fighting the good fight
sure but let's be realistic about the
business prospects of what he did on X
like you mentioned Alex Jones's audience
still exists so the analogy I gave
earlier on my channel was like the poll
Elon Musk did was like imagine you owned
a cupcake shop and all your customers
are in the lobby and you just yell how
many of you would buy a pumpkin cupcake
and they all raised their hand well then
you go and make it it's it's that that's
it Elon mus is asking his customers what
kind of product they want but here's the
funny thing just like with the daily
wire making all these movies Elon Musk
is looking at Alex Jones getting
millions of views while being banned
from everywhere and he's thinking if I
let Alex Jones on Twitter I have a
monopoly on Alex Jones all his content
is going to be here it's going to bring
all of his fans back it's going to bring
engagement to the platform we're going
to make money let's roll and it pushes
the Overton window and I think it's not
an accident that a lot of this is
happening on the heels of Apple Disney
Comcast and other major corporations
saying hey uh we're no longer going to
advertise on of course Twitter and X
Elon Musk responded saying uh in a very
French way screw off and by doing so
this is he he could say it but but when
his actions are are met by bringing back
Alex Jones that's the biggest F off kind
of moment that you could have that are
far more powerful than just the words
that he used but but but imagine because
it's not just you know these
corporations it's not just Facebook it's
it's not just uh YouTube it's not it's
not individuals Banning Alex Jones from
all these social media platforms there
are federal agents that orchestrated all
of this there are federal AG agencies
that literally worked on silencing and
making sure that no one could hear Alex
Jones his opinions or his perspectives
at all imagine being that federal agent
right now a couple years ago be like yes
we we banned them on Spotify we banned
them on on all these other LinkedIn he's
not even on LinkedIn doesn't matter we
banned him here we banned him here we
banned him here and now he's on one of
the biggest shows with Elon Musk
speaking to the world with millions of
people listening to him and more and
more people are going to go to that
platform I know I am one one of our
super chats Greg duvier says that he's
asking the elites would still have
control of Twitter if they didn't uh ban
The Babylon B and I said I said I bet
they regret that every day I don't think
that's the real reason Elon Musk bought
Twitter and I say this because I was at
a party in Austin with a bunch of big
Tech Bros and people who are friends
with with Elon and a bunch of other
conservative commentators and
Libertarians and the whole conversation
was around how they use big Tech to
censor and control culture and I was
arguing with them like guys culture is
more important than technology
technology is important but like winning
the culture matters and their argument
Elon wasn't there anything but their
argument was basically if they ban you
you can't make culture at all if on
Twitter they have banned all instances
of a certain word then they are forcing
you know they've basically created
created a a path that only the only path
you can go down and so unsurprisingly El
Elon ends up buying the platform it may
be that the final straw was the Babylon
be got banned I think that's a good
narrative especially for someone like
Elon but I I I kind of feel like this is
a long time coming I think elon's paying
attention to all this stuff he didn't
adopt these views one day you know it's
not like all a sudden he like what they
banned The Babylon be all of a sudden
I'm for free speech oh he he's probably
supported this stuff for a very long
time yeah and I think well it's a
similar concept to kind of the Sigh up
of every single conservative needs to
move out of cities here's the reality
somebody has to make a cultural
difference and right now the only way to
really do that is to have some sort of
uh influence on it in cities where the
cultural hubs are now is that good
culture that we have right now no but
it's the same thing as social media
platforms like as much as we don't want
to have to participate in you know
walking around uh walking on eggshells
when it comes to these social media
platforms like we did for so long with
Twitter we have to have a presence on
these apps on these social media
Platforms in order to make some sort of
cultural change as conservative
and so I think you're right Elon did the
right thing Elon did something where he
saw okay well the only way for this for
there to be a fair sort of you know
cultural balance out there would be to
give conservatives the opportunity to be
on this app and uh I think it he it
wasn't necessarily like a political move
per se although he'll argue he's free
speech I don't think the guy is I don't
I I I think that if he were he would
bring back Nick Fuentes um and I think
that he wouldn't have created the poll
and maybe we differ on that or we
disagree on that but I think that the
poll was all about self-preservation and
was more about and and to to be fair
feds would have come after him too so to
your point like you know there were feds
involved in silencing people like Alex
Jones and even Nick ventes and others
like that so uh I think it's all about
well I can point back to this was the
people's decision and they might still
come after him but at the end of the day
like I do think that was partly an
opportunity for himself to Pro for him
to protect himself but I think
ultimately he did it for there to be
some sort of balance out there which I I
think is good but again not necessarily
politically motivated that's that's a
good point uh if he was for free speech
he wouldn't need a poll he'd just say
Alex you're fine Nick you're fine Milo
you're fine you're back don't worry
about it they wouldn't have banned Kanye
West yay is still banned right I believe
so and so so as well yay posted the
realism symbol which looks like a star
of Dave with a swastika in it but
realism like what what is it like they
believe aliens or something seated Earth
I don't I don't know what they believe
but it but it it to those who have no
idea what it is it looks like something
meant to be offensive he gets banned for
this I think if Elon was for free speech
he wouldn't need a poll that's a good
point and I think maybe elon's
motivation is actually simple he wants
to colonize Mars he wants neuralink and
he's thinking look that that Meme he
posted where it's the left moving
further and further left he's realized
what many of us have realized you said
as conservatives I don't consider myself
conservative and Luke doesn't consider
himself conservative this Coalition of
individuals who believe in free speech
is is is wide Elon probably said the
majority of people think these things I
wouldn't be surprised if he had like a
marketing consultant and he was like
where is the sentiment are they really
you know Lefty and woke and they're like
no it's probably like 12% elon's like
okay so our path forward for popular
success is going to be embracing these
principles that people actually do like
yeah he he probably sees the wind moving
in a particular direction especially
with this election and he's like okay
how do we get ahead of it how do we put
our sales in a way where we could still
win while the whole system kind of
collapses onto itself so I I I agree
with you on on that one particular Point
yes he's trying to kind of protect
himself with this poll but but I don't
think it's even the poll I think it's
even bigger than this if you look at his
contracts with the defense industry with
the US military with the Pentagon when
it comes to starlink when it comes to
providing Ukraine and Israel satellite
technology that are used for defensive
and offensive capabilities those
capabilities are at his disposal to use
and Implement as he wants that to me in
my opinion is why he's going to be kind
of protected here and if it wasn't for
those kind of larger government
contracts and the larger kind of game
that he plays with a lot of the bigger
kind of um players here I think he would
have been gone I think he would have
been destroyed a long time ago and I
think this really does play a central
role in a lot of this so I got Alex
Jones pulled over right here and one of
his tweets from 22 minutes ago Jack
bobic issues emergency warning deep
State planning direct war with Russia as
October surprise now excuse me this is
from uh Jack bobic Alex Jones putting
out this information this is exactly why
they don't want Alex Jones having a
voice cuz y'all remember when Alex Jones
went on the show and said that come
February there's going to be a war it's
going to be big and uh then when Russia
invaded Ukraine everybody immediately
was tweeting Alex Jones was right he
predicted this they were all sharing
this clip from several months prior my
favorite thing about this is everyone's
like how did Alex Jones know a war was
going to start how did he know he's just
so smart he can see it and so I I talked
to him and he was like I just read the
news it was in the news like it this is
the funny thing Alex is a guy who reads
the news and then says it he like looks
at all these articles and brings them
together granted he says a lot of crazy
things he gets crazy things wrong like
he was talking about cell phones and
animal hybrids whatever that's about but
he gets a lot of things right when it
comes to this stuff it wasn't shocking
to anybody who actually listens to him
that he accurately called out a war
because all he was doing was holding up
like articles from the AP that's what
he's doing here with retweeting Jack
bobic he's not actually saying exactly
that's my point and it's not just him
it's members of the Polish government
members of the German government coming
out one of German's uh Germany's top
solders just came out and said that they
are of course planning on potentially
even having a defensive war against
Russia of course there's there's no such
thing it's an offensive War but this is
something that it's not just Alex Jones
talking about government officials are
actually talking about this and setting
down essentially the groundwork for what
could be a big potential conflict that
could potentially uh unfold especially
right before this election thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at Tim cast.com for
uncensored membersonly shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time